this is the first time you're speaking  publicly  i had no need to talk to the media  they were looking for sensationalism and  they were looking for the monster  police found 29 bodies buried in shallow  graves under gacy's suburban chicago  home  it's a very good neighbor we socialize  with them  gacy was well respected in his community  and even dressed up as a clown to  entertain children  he said to me clowns can get away with  murder  gacy was convicted of murdering more  people than anyone else in u.s history  it had nothing to do with the bodies the  dead won't bother you it's the living  you got to worry about  there were red flags all along the way  that for some reason nobody paid  attention to  we're learning so much now we would  never have known at the time  could gacy have done this alone maybe  there's a cover up here  mom protected john she curied secrets  she went to the grave with  the thing everybody thought they knew  wasn't the whole story  you